مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
يَا عَنْزَاتِي يَا عَنْزَاتِي
مَا أَحْلَاكِ مَا أَحْلَاكِ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
يَا عَنْزَاتِي يَا عَنْزَاتِي
مَا أَحْلَاكِ مَا أَحْلَاكِ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
في المَزْرَعَةِ مَاءْ مَاءْ  *** تَأْكُلُ عُشْبًا تَشْرَبُ مَاء
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ   مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
مَنْ رَدَّدَ فِي المَرْعَى مَاءْ
ذَاتَ صَبَاحٍ مَاءْ مَاءْ
جَاءَ الثَّعْلَبْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
رَتَّبَ مَقْلَبْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
يَلْبَسُ كَالفَلَّاحِ رِدَاءْ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ   مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
مَنْ رَدَّدَ فِي المَرْعَى مَاءْ
ظَلَّ الثَّعْلَبْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
فِي مَرْعَاكُمْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
كَيْ يَخْدَعَكُمْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
أَوْ يَسْرِقَ أَحَدَ الأَبْنَاءْ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ  مَاءْ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ   مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
مَنْ رَدَّدَ فِي المَرْعَى مَاءْ
لَكِنْ عَنْزَاتِي مَاءْ مَاءْ
فَضَحَتْ فِعْلَهْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
وَكَشَفَتْ ذَيْلَهْ مَاءْ مَاءْ
عَادَ يَجُرُّهُ بَعْدَ عَنَاءْ
مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ مَاءْ   مَاءْ